Jagdish Bhagwati a university professor
of economics and law at Columbia
University I have read for as I'm sure a
lot of people have Simon Schama is great
book on the embarrassment of riches
about the Dutch burghers who accumulated
wealth but then spend it on themselves
but spend it on social purposes so
that's also the Calvinist approach and
where I come from you know in India the
latter I come from the state rate of the
great madman Gandhi was and he inherited
a tradition didn't create one but
basically people would accumulate wealth
like man they would pay your penny more
than the market would in terms of wages
but all the money they made went into
into education health they did even
things like dry farming experiments to
improve agriculture
it's a relying of the government so
we've had an enormous tradition in
several communities so there are lots of
places for which you get the least
important one in my opinion this is is
where your work
I found studies where people actually
had risk you know responded to increase
incomes as a result of improved export
market earnings not by saying wickedly
oh that now I can get so much more money
by putting my child to work that I'm
gonna take one more child out of school
and put a put her into work instead they
were acting virtuously and saying look
now that I've got more money for from
the same amount of export of rice for
instance from Vietnam I'm now going to
be able to take one child away from work
and put her into school instead so keep
going the other way
on the contrary globalization which of
course depends on mark being able to
exploit markets and keeping markets open
and so on where multinational also
naturally play a role because they go
out and you know create jobs and so on
but all of this is actually good for you
good for globalized is good for morality
because what is morality if it's not
about improving the lives of people now
and if you can create jobs and pull
people out of poverty into more gainful
employment on a sustained basis that's a
good thing not a bad thing it has to be
consistent with your moral values
poor parents are even more mindful of
this than rich parents you know if we
can reach Paris or leave a lot of money
behind for their children but the poor
parents do invest in children and as we
all know from the usual you know the
casual empiricism that a poor man will
share his last burrito with you and the
rich guy I probably won't let you sit
down at his banquet
Adam Smith pointed out that you know men
have self-interest he didn't say it was
that was the only thing they have
because the Theory of Moral Sentiments
he does find out that man is a more
complex creature so he's more like what
rabbi Hillel said which is you know if
I'm not for others what a mind if I am
NOT for myself who will be so we are all
a mixture of self-interest and hand the
less baisemeaux desert work namely
altruism and empathy but it's in
different mixtures Adams most great
genius was to say that and so far as
you're pursuing your self-interest your
basest motive is at where you might say
right that we can devise an
institutional structure namely Marcus
him and then but it wasn't just Marcus
in his case he was more complex person
on the economic design as well but by
and large Marcus that is the way in
which you translate that self-interest
or greed if you want to call it into
three into use socially desirable
outcomes that was his genius
got frayed at the margin because of all
these CEOs with lots of money but I
don't need was he in a quantity part
that was really the problem because what
they saw was people just getting out of
failing enterprise with large sums of
bonuses and and their payments often
with insider information that clearing
out first and the way I see it it has
nothing to do with inequality or justice
but we Indians and Asians and so on
I'm not brought up like like Americans
and Western children because you you
guys actually you know I brought up on
the notion that when a ship is going
down the captain should be on board and
he sink with the boat and and the
passengers go in lifeboats here they see
it exactly the other way around the
passengers are going down you know the
workers are going down with the ship and
the captain isn't going away in the
lifeboat I think that is necessarily I
mean it's it's just so clearly unethical
in terms of the way you brought up to
think about what should be the way you
behave in a crisis right and I said this
does I was never brought up on this
notion do I being a good person well I
never even thought about it when I was a
child but all of you have been brought
up that way that is something which
really created finally a big sense that
somehow the system was unethical
America's etiology I often say his lack
of etiology oh you know it's like the
editor of The Economist who was asked so
Jeffery krauser at one time what's the
philosophy of your magazine and he said
we are in the extreme center that's what
Americans are basically and you look at
the way they're reacting to the crisis
how to handle it
Sarkozy starts reading Das Kapital and
my reaction was I thought every French
freshman when he was at school read Marx
and Bruce and Walter how come he he lost
out on a good education and has to read
us capital now but he makes an
ideological point you see where's our
chaps settle down to business you're
accused of socialism what's so bad
because they do whatever is necessary to
get you out of this crisis